[Matt] Now…
Is there such a thing as too much custard?
-[chuckles] No.
-[Noel] No
-…it's Custard Week…
-So I'm ready for you, ice cream.
…with a signature
where no one wants to sink to the bottom…
-[Syabira] Float the island.
-[Sandro] Float, baby, float.
[Matt] …a technical with a timed twist…
-What? [giggles]
-[Sandro] What?
Feels like being summoned
into a naughty tent.
-[Matt] …and a showstopper…
-I wish I had three arms, honestly.
…where the custard
must hold itself together…
-It's quite wobbly.
-[Syabira] Super jiggly.
-[Abdul] Jiggle-jiggle.
-[Matt] …as much as the bakers.
[Kevin] Oh, no.
The freezer is four degree.
It's gonna be melting.
[opening theme music playing]
[Sandro] There's so many
custard things you can make.
There's a custard slice.
-They could do pain aux raisin again.
-No.
Last week was amazing, I would say that.
I was wondering
if I ever gonna be a Star Baker,
and once I got it,
I hope everyone else will get it as well.
[Abdul] It is Custard Week,
so there's a lot that can go wrong.
With confidence,
it's in the mid-ground at the moment.
[Syabira] ♪ Custard, custard, custard! ♪
[Kevin] I love making custard.
There's so much you can do.
You get crème anglaise,
crème pâtissière, crème au beurre…
I had no idea
there were so many varieties of custard.
…crème légère,
crème chiboust, crème mousseline.
Thought custard was just custard.
Bonjour, mes amis.
Welcome back to le grande blanc tante.
For your signature challenge,
Paul and Prue would like you to create
your take on the classic French dessert,
île flottantes,
which is foreign for floating islands.
The judges are looking
for eight perfect portions
of poached meringue floating on a sea
of silky smooth crème anglaise.
[Matt] The flavours are up to you.
The judges just want to see
some beautifully presented floaters.
-[Noel] You have an hour and a half.
-On your marks…
-Get set…
-Bake.
I never heard of floating island before.
Heard of floaters, not floating island.
Last time I had a floating island
is when I last practised it,
and it was absolutely filth.
Bit of a funny one. I like the custard,
but not a fan of poached meringue.
Reminds me of baby food a bit. [chuckles]
It's Custard Week this week.
One of my favourite things to eat ever.
Now they've got to make
eight floating islands.
Basically, they're a poached meringue
floating in English custard.
Crème anglaise.
I normally buy custard
because it's much easier
to go and get a 50p can, innit?
[chuckles]
[Paul] We want to see
colour, flavour, and texture.
I'm just gonna make eight little biscuits.
Lychee. Ugh! They're like eyeballs.
I always like making floating islands.
Silky smooth and light,
it melts in the mouth.
They are the most delicious.
[Noel] How's it feel after last week,
'cause you got a handshake,
and you won the technical,
and you won Star Baker?
That is actually a very nice achievement,
but we all back to the clean slate.
Who are you? What are you doing now?
[Syabira] I'm making mojito cocktail.
[Noel] Mojitos.
Now you're talking my language.
[Matt] Syabira's meringues will be coated
in a layer of sand crumble,
flavoured with mint leaves and lime zest.
Her crème anglaise
will be presented in bowls
painted with palm trees
to complete her mojito islands.
[Syabira] Only mojito lover
can live in that mojito island.
Everything that you sell
will be only mojito.
Mojito cake, mojito-flavoured,
mojito toast, mojito jam.
Rather than saying,
"Good morning," you say, "Mojito."
[Matt] And if the judges need something
to sober them up after Syabira's mojitos,
Janusz has just the recipe
for the morning after.
I've decided to celebrate
my favourite morning drink, vanilla latte.
-So it's gonna be--
-I thought it was gonna be Bovril.
-No! [laughs]
-You've got coffee in the custard.
Two espressos, and looks like latte.
-[Paul] Nice.
-It's a really nice idea.
[Matt] Janusz's floating Island
nods to his perfect breakfast
with a coffee and vanilla crème anglaise
served with
a bite-sized marmalade-flavoured biscuit.
Is this the first time
you've come across it?
I had it before in Poland.
We call it soup of nothing.
-[laughs]
-[Prue] Soup of nothing?
That's how floating island should be,
just disappear in your mouth.
Yes.
I'm making the custard.
There's milk and double cream.
I'll add orange zest and vanilla paste.
[Matt] Not only are Paul and Prue
expecting perfectly smooth crème anglaise…
[Syabira] I'll have
lime and rum crème anglaise.
Judges gonna be smashed! [laughs]
…they also want it
to have a perfectly balanced taste.
Rose can really easily become
an overpowering flavour.
I always stop
just before I think I should.
I'm just gonna add some cardamom.
[Matt] Sandro's taking it a step further
and going all out
with his flavour profiles.
I've not had that "wow"
with the flavours yet.
I've just had, "Oh, it tastes nice."
Which is great,
but I want that, "Oh-hoo-hoo-hoo!"
[Matt] His flavours
bring together crème anglaise
with a cherry jelly, chocolate shavings,
and a caramelised
almond and hazelnut topping.
Plus, he's bringing in a boozy element
to give the wow factor he's after.
The custard, it's gonna be brandy-infused,
and I've got cherry jelly
with a bit of rosé Prosecco in there.
-Have you practised this?
-I have practised it.
I thought it's a bit too simple,
so I added the alcohol.
I'm just really trying to make sure
the flavours are all well-balanced.
[Matt] Kevin's also adding
a tipple for the judges…
Never tried popping Prosecco with a sword.
I do it safely with a towel over the cork.
…but it's not the custard
he's adding it to.
The meringue
will be favoured with Prosecco.
-How much?
-Eight tablespoons.
It'll deflate, but as long as
you whisk it enough, it comes back.
[Matt] Kevin's Prosecco meringue
will float in a sea of rose crème anglaise
topped with lychee and raspberry coulis.
Keeping with the island theme,
his decoration will be a tuile biscuit
coloured pink to look like tropical coral.
Could've done an island
in the middle of a loch.
-Ugh. That'd be too cliché.
-[laughter]
-Could've done Nessie.
-Nessie, sort of…
[Prue] Nessie in a loch.
[Noel] Matt, like my cake?
It's a Pac-Man cake.
Didn't Pac-Man have an eye?
Yeah, he had an eye, yeah. Thanks.
-[laughs] Thanks for your help.
-Yeah.
[imitating Pac-Man music]
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Right, now I can pour it inside
this mixture of eggs and sugar.
[Kevin] Get it back in the pan
and cook it until it's thickened.
[Matt] Custard needs to be cooked
low and slow to get the consistency right.
A lot can go wrong. The custard
can be overcooked or undercooked.
[Matt] It's a process
that cannot be rushed.
[Syabira] You need to whisk
until it's thickened.
Strong arms.
[Matt] Cook it too quick
and the eggs will scramble…
You mustn't boil it.
It shouldn't get above
about 80-85 degrees.
…but remove it from the heat too soon
and it will not thicken enough
and the floating islands will sink.
This is taking years to thicken up.
I am quite patient,
but this is just… [laughs]
Just… just a bit too much!
[Matt] Maxy's poached meringue
will sit in a lagoon
of crème anglaise and blueberry sauce.
It'll be topped with
caramelised sugar swirls and glitter dust.
I've seen people
actually lose years of their lives
-stirring custard.
-Stirring away?
Thinking it won't happen,
and suddenly it does.
-Yeah, it does.
-They get real excited.
-Have you ever stirred custard, Matt?
-I get the birds to do it.
-[laughs]
-See what I've done there?
It's a bit thicker.
-[Kevin] Think we're done.
-[Abdul] Looking good.
-The right texture.
-This is kind of done.
It looks really runny,
but it should be all right.
[Matt] With custards completed
and left to cool…
[Sandro] Pop it in the fridge.
Er, meringue. Am I right or a meringue?
[Matt] …the bakers move on to making
the all-important meringue islands.
I'm making a French meringue style.
I whisked my egg whites to a soft paste.
Now I'm adding sugar.
Gradually.
[Abdul] Once it reaches stiff peaks
and all my sugar is there,
I will then shape them
and start poaching them in water.
[Matt] Abdul's poached meringue
will be topped with caramel swirls
and sit in an orange crème anglaise
marbled with a cherry coulis.
-[Noel] Something you've made before?
-[Abdul] I'd never seen these before.
You're quite good with meringue.
My wife's made of meringue.
Oh? [laughs]
She was. She's just an eggy liquid
in the bottom of a pan now.
-[chuckles]
-But, you know…
-Interesting.
-We still get on.
So the show's been getting
a few letters of complaint
that we've been stressing
the bakers out with our time calls,
and that we need to be
a little bit more soothing.
-Okay.
-So I've been practising.
-Kind of soothing time call.
-Ready?
-Yes.
[high-pitched] Bakers!
[chuckles] You have half an hour left!
[chuckles]
Let's not panic just yet.
I'll do eight tablespoons of Prosecco.
It'll deflate,
but give it a chance to whip back up.
[Matt] Whipping the meringue
to the right degree is crucial.
Stiff and glossy.
[Matt] Not enough, and it won't be
firm enough to hold its shape.
[Abdul] This is abstract art.
[Matt] Making it tricky to successfully
form identical floating islands…
Just try to get them as same as possible.
…that will hold firm
in liquid for poaching.
It's gonna be very generous portion.
I don't want to be called a stingy lady.
[Janusz] Gonna pipe meringue
to look like latte foam.
But, yeah, my hands are literally shaking.
-Have you been drinking?
-[laughing] No, not for a long time now.
I'm gonna begin poaching. So I'm gonna
poach my meringues in the milk.
[Syabira] Let's try the first one.
I'm gonna poach them
for two minutes on each side.
Everyone will be poaching
their meringues in liquid.
Mine rely on steam
because you will destroy the piping.
My meringues have gone wrong.
They're too soft and totally collapsed.
-It's like the Titanic, little icebergs.
-In what way?
-Little mini icebergs.
-I thought you meant the tragic ending.
[laughing] No!
If you touch them on the outside,
and they look fluffy, it's almost ready.
At least, that's what I think.
[imperceptible]
[Syabira] That looks good. It's done.
-[Janusz] Floaters are done.
-[Matt] What you looking at?
I'm looking at that magic over there.
-Oh, yeah. I know.
-[hissing]
[hisses]
Yours look like that.
[laughing] Yeah.
[Kevin] These are not good. A bit rough.
[Syabira] Put them in the minty sand.
[both] Bakers, you have 15 minutes.
[Sandro] Putting the custard in.
Prosecco jellies have set.
[Syabira] It's a minty sand
topped with the crème anglaise.
[Kevin] Nice bit of
retro kitsch glassware.
[Janusz] This coffee smells good.
There we are, baby.
I'm gonna jazz this up now.
-[Abdul] This is my cherry coulis.
-Right. Meringues next.
[Janusz] They're very delicate things.
[Syabira] Float the island.
[Sandro] Float, baby, float.
I mean, they do float.
[Kevin] Oh, that's a sorry-looking one.
-[Syabira] How long do I have left?
-Bakers, you have one minute left.
-[Abdul] Oh, boy.
-[Syabira] Time pressure.
[Abdul] Just final decorations.
So this is a raspberry and lychee coulis.
-[Maxy] Blueberry sauce.
-[Sandro] Add the hazelnuts.
[Kevin] Oh, coral tuile is ready.
[Abdul] Caramel decorations.
[Maxy] Think I'm just rushing a bit.
This is looking a mess.
See.
[Janusz] My hands are literally shaking.
Too much coffee.
[chuckles]
[Maxy] Oh, my God!
Bakers, your time is up.
Please step away
from your floating islands.
Oh, that's cool.
They look like coated, breaded chicken.
-[Maxy] Yeah.
-[Abdul laughing] Coated, breaded chicken?
That's the last thing
I want to hear, Sandro.
[Syabira chuckles]
[Matt] The bakers' floating islands
will now face
the judgement of Paul and Prue.
-[Paul] Hi, Syabira.
-[Prue] Hello.
I actually thought
it was a deep-fried chicken.
-Sitting in béchamel sauce.
-That's delicious as well.
[all laughing]
I think it is a floating desert island.
It's covered in sand.
[Paul] It does look great.
It is a lime crème anglaise
topped with the meringue,
coated with the minty sand.
As always,
there's nothing wrong with your flavours.
They're fresh, they're very distinct.
And your meringue is beautifully poached.
[Paul] It's a great mojito.
The custard is perfect.
The lime's got a sharpness
that cuts through. So it's not too sweet.
-Very clever.
-Well done, Syabira.
You're in some kind of crazy groove.
[chuckles]
They look nice. Quite attractive.
The meringue's lost its height
because of the weight of the caramel.
You have orange custard.
[Prue] Look at that custard.
And then we have a cherry coulis.
It is absolutely delicious.
It's very sweet, but the custard's
an excellent flavour. I love the orange.
-Okay.
-I'd like to see the meringue more robust.
Looks quite appetising.
I'm not sure it's enough for a dessert.
Combination of flavours
is really delicious.
The acidity of the purée
sets off the meringue's
sweetness perfectly. It's lovely.
The blueberry's
got a lovely tartness to it.
But the crème anglaise
could have been a little bit thicker.
-It's quite effective.
-Looks like a latte.
Your crème anglaise texture
is absolutely perfect. It's thick enough.
As a latte goes, it's delicious.
Just enough coffee in there.
Very delicate,
and I love the flavour and texture.
It's delicious.
I'm really tempted to keep going,
but I won't 'cause I've got more to come.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] Thanks.
-[Paul] I think it looks busy.
-[Prue] I do think they look quite pretty.
You have the cherry jelly,
bit of Prosecco,
spiced custard with brandy…
Certainly got brandy in it.
[Paul] Certainly has.
It's very alcoholic.
I think the custard is perfect
from a texture point of view.
Would've been better
not to have Prosecco in the jelly…
Okay.
…because the brandy is quite enough.
You got carried away.
-[Paul] Thank you.
-Thank you.
[Paul] The puree, it's probably
slightly watered it down.
-Slackened off the crème anglaise.
-[Kevin] Mmm-hmm.
The custard is smooth as anything.
I love the Prosecco.
It's a lovely, light mouthful,
but it does mean that the islands
are a bit squashed.
Meringues have disintegrated
with the Prosecco.
So the alcohol
has broken the meringue apart.
-The lychee is delicious.
-[Prue] Mmm.
Thank you.
[Kevin] That was another mixed one.
Bottom of a pretty good bunch
is an okay place to be. [laughs]
Paul said it looks like
a chicken on béchamel.
But they said the custard was perfect.
I'm very pleased.
Too much going on.
It was too busy, which it was.
Game plan going into the technical
is I'm sitting at the back.
So I got the whole view to see
what everyone else is doing. [laughs]
[Matt] The Bakers were able
to practise their floating islands,
but have no idea what awaits them
in the technical challenge.
Well, bakers, it's time
for your technical challenge
which today has been set
by Prue-be-doo-be-doo.
Prue-be-doo, any words of advice?
Take your time and keep your cool.
That cannot be it.
-That is it.
-[Noel laughing]
As ever, this technical challenge
will be judged blind.
So we're gonna have to ask
these two to hop it.
[angrily] Go on, get out of it.
Don't want you around here.
[normally] For your technical challenge,
we're gonna do something different.
We're gonna have a staggered start time
and a staggered finish time.
-What? [giggles]
-[Sandro] What?
Everybody leave the tent
except for Sandro.
-[laughter]
-What?
-[Janusz] Bye-bye!
-No, but wait.
[Maxy] What is going on?
[exhales]
No pressure.
The judges would like you to make
six pistachio and praline ice cream cones.
Your cones should be dipped
in chocolate and nuts.
And then topped
with a pistachio and praline ice cream.
You have two hours and 45 minutes.
On your marks…
-Get set…
-Bake.
[Sandro] This is
the most nervous I've felt.
Normally, the other bakers are here.
So I get to see if I'm on the right track.
But today, all alone.
Pistachio and praline
ice cream cone for a technical,
this is a first.
It's Custard Week,
and to make good ice cream,
you have to make good custard.
I'd like there to be at least
one and a half scoops in there.
I always feel cheated when I get a cone
and there's just a little mound on top.
They have to make their own cones.
They should be golden brown, not pale.
And if they are too dark,
they'll be too brittle.
-And you get that nasty--
-Slightly burnt taste.
[Prue] One of the tricky things
about this challenge is the timing.
If they don't get their ice cream
frozen properly,
we are going to have pistachio soup.
And we're doing staggered starts to
make it absolutely fair when we judge it.
Should we try them?
Mmm, that is beautiful.
The cone is crispy,
silky-smooth ice cream.
The texture from
the praline inside is lovely.
It's really good,
strong pistachio flavour.
Even on a cold day,
having ice cream,
actually, doesn't really matter.
-Tastes great.
-I know.
[Sandro] Never even heard
of a custard ice cream.
It needs to be frozen,
so gotta be pretty quick.
To begin with,
it says to make crème anglaise.
This is a mixture
of double cream and milk.
I'm gonna wait until it starts to simmer,
which is already, it's getting there.
-Come join the party, baker two.
-[Noel] Join us.
The judges would like you to make
six pistachio and praline ice cream cones.
You have two hours 45 minutes.
On your marks…
-Get set…
-Bake.
[Janusz] It is very empty and very quiet.
I think more or less
I know what I'm doing.
So I'm ready for you, ice cream.
These eggs will be creamed
with some sugar.
And then mix that in…
[Noel] Baker three, would you join us?
Don't look so frightened. You're okay.
The judges would like you to make
six pistachio and praline ice cream cones.
On your marks…
-Get set…
-Bake.
[Syabira chuckling] This is weird.
Oh, just feels like being summoned
into a naughty tent.
Just like, we've been naughty, haven't we?
Never made ice cream with custard.
Need to get this crème anglaise
to cool down as soon as I can.
That was weird.
It was strange
being the only person in here.
-Made anything like this before?
-Never made ice cream before.
It's not a thing, innit?
When the ice cream man
comes over to your road
and he parks in front of the house.
You don't go, "Sorry, love,
we make our own."
"We made it already." Yeah.
[Noel] Hello, baker four.
-On your marks…
-Get set…
Bake.
I don't know anything
about ice cream, to be honest.
I've got no idea. Clueless.
[nervous chuckle]
Let's just start.
The key is to keep an eye
on the custard when it's cooking
so you don't get scrambled eggs.
It needs to be cooked on the stove
until it gets thickened.
[Noel] Baker number five.
[Matt] On your marks…
-Get set…
-Bake.
[Kevin] I've made ice cream before.
Got an ice cream maker at home.
I can do this.
It's just like being at home.
I'm looking for my custard to thicken up
until it can coat the back of a spoon.
[Sandro] Going to do it thicker
than my floating island custard.
[Noel] Baker six,
would you like to join us?
[Matt] On your marks…
-Get set…
-Bake.
[Abdul] Yes, the last one in.
First time I'm making ice cream.
First time I'm seeing this machine.
So, let's see. [laughs]
[Syabira] Crème anglaise is nearly ready.
Happy with the way it looks.
-[Noel] It's a bit crazy. Staggered.
-[Syabira] I know!
Maybe it's because of the ice cream.
They don't want it melted.
-Yeah. That is--
-When the next judges--
Quite breezy here, isn't it? [chuckles]
-Yeah, it's very breezy.
-It's like a gale.
[Sandro] I've made my crème anglaise.
It's looking pretty decent.
I'm happy with it.
It's gonna go to the ice bath.
So it's cool enough
for the ice cream machine.
[Matt] The bakers must reduce
the temperature
of their crème anglaise
as quickly as possible.
-[Sandro] In the fridge.
-[Maxy] In the fridge.
[Matt] But where they cool it is crucial.
You can't put a hot crème anglaise
into the freezer.
Er, the temperature difference,
it might cause an issue.
[Kevin] Into the fridge.
[Syabira] I chill in the freezer
to get it down as fast as I can.
[Matt] Adding warm crème anglaise
to a freezer
will cause the freezer's
temperature to rise.
[Janusz] Now it can go to the freezer.
[Matt] And may prevent the ice cream
from setting later in the challenge.
-[Sandro] It's cooled, which is good.
-[Kevin] Yeah, that's ready.
[Maxy] I am adding in my pistachio paste.
I'm gonna add the food colouring.
Pistachios shouldn't have too much colour.
It says to churn and then to freeze.
[Sandro] When it's thick and ice-creamy,
I'll turn it off,
however long that will take.
Probably take about 45 minutes to churn.
I don't know.
If this works out,
I'll be so proud of myself.
[Sandro] Now I'm gonna
make the… [snaps fingers]
…waffle cones.
I've got an idea of how it's done.
Gonna whip up my egg whites,
then sift in the flour and icing sugar,
fold in the butter.
-[Sandro] Looks good.
-Looks the right consistency.
[Janusz] Gonna start cooking them now.
[Sandro] I'm gonna go for it.
I'm just gonna trust the press.
-First one is in.
-[Kevin] Lid is on.
I give them two minutes
and wait patiently.
-Pop it in three minutes.
-Five, four minutes.
I need this to be golden.
Three, two…
[Janusz] Hello?
Not there yet.
[sighs]
[Sandro] Yeah! I'm going for
a golden-y type colour and just roll it.
Not brown, just golden.
[Syabira] Once done, you need
to roll straight away and let it set.
[Kevin] Tighter at the bottom.
[Maxy] Something is burning.
Something's burning. Or is it me?
[gasps] No!
Oh, what!
[exhales]
Just made an ice cream cone.
That's pretty cool. [chuckles]
-It's six, right?
-Go again.
[Abdul] I'm gonna do it for less time.
[Kevin] Oh, that's better.
[Syabira] Ow, it's so hot.
[Janusz] Well,
I definitely didn't perfect it.
[Noel] Look at that! [whistles]
-Hmm.
-Ever done that before?
Never made a waffle cone before.
-You just did that--
-Obsessed with waffle cones now.
[Noel] You getting a waffle cone maker?
Feels fine.
-[both laughing]
-Don't try that at home, children.
Burning, burning, burning.
I smell burning.
Oh, man. They burned. What is going on?
Okay, even less time than that.
-[Kevin] Final one.
-[Abdul scatting]
[Maxy] That is six.
This one is okay. This one also okay.
I'm moving on to next step.
Make the praline.
Caramelise my sugar.
Put it on top of the pistachios.
[Matt] When I was a kid, you had
pistachio ice cream on holiday.
-Yeah.
-[Matt] From the Algarve.
Sort of like, "Oh, they've got pistachio."
[laughs]
"Ron, they've got pistachio, did you want
pistachio. You like pistachio."
"No, just vanilla.
He just wants a vanilla."
[Janusz] It's getting there, baby.
I'm just gonna stop churning it.
It's pretty thick.
I think it's done.
Scrape the ice cream into a bowl
and fold through the praline. Freeze.
-Make sure that's all in there.
-Now it can go to the freezer.
[Sandro] I need this to set quick, quick.
It's gonna freeze. Should be okay.
[Abdul] I will be leaving this
in the freezer for as long as possible.
Dip the ice cream cone rims
in melted chocolate,
-then in chopped pistachios.
-[Janusz] Pistachios on my wafer.
I'm gonna put some
melted chocolate in the cone.
-Yeah.
-I'll put that in there.
-[Noel] Just gonna do that?
-Yeah.
[Noel] Like a little secret extra. Wow!
[Syabira] I hope my ice cream is freezing.
[Janusz] I'm gonna see my ice cream.
It's too soft.
[Sandro] It's set, I'm happy, happy.
The freezer is four degree.
It's gonna be melting.
Ah, stress!
I'm praying really hard silently
so my ice cream set.
Baker number one,
you have five minutes until judgement.
[Sandro] It's cold. Everything's cold now.
How many scoops do they want?
I'll try do two, then I've just gotta
drizzle chocolate sauce.
I'm gonna do it in the freezer
the rest of this.
[Sandro] A little bit of the sauce.
Baker number two, you have five minutes.
Baker number one, I am coming
to get your bake now for judging.
[whispering] Happy?
Sir. Madam.
These look quite attractive.
[Prue] They've managed
to get two balls on.
[Paul] The green's right as well,
the colour.
-The cone is absolutely lovely. Crisp.
-Hmm.
[mutters]
It's nice and creamy,
the ice cream, and set.
[Prue] The baker has filled the inside--
-[Paul] With chocolate.
-Stops the ice cream sogging it up.
[Prue] That is delicious.
[exhales heavily]
My ice cream didn't set.
[Maxy whispering] It's so hard to make.
[Janusz] It's like water.
Baker number three,
you have five minutes left.
Baker number two. I'm coming for ya.
[whispering] Okay.
Thank you.
That looks like it's been
in the sun for six hours.
Falling out of the bottom.
The cone seems to be crisp enough.
The praline's good.
It's good flavour, but it's just not set.
[Syabira] Freezer didn't cool down.
My ice cream is melting.
I feel like I want
to give up this challenge.
If it melts, it melts.
I did my best. [chuckles]
Baker number three,
I'm coming to get your bake right now.
-[whispering] Thank you.
-Thank you. Ah, it's melting.
I'll get it there quick.
-There you go.
-[Paul] It's soft. It's not set.
It's just like liquid.
[Prue] Er…
-[Paul] Hmm.
-[Prue exclaims]
It's leaking all over. Even down the side.
Because the ice cream is so unset,
the praline doesn't have the proper
crunch it should.
Sort of pistachio soup.
[Syabira] It's fine.
Seems fairly stable.
I was gonna do a second scoop,
but I don't think I will.
Baker number four, your time is up.
[Prue] The ice cream looks set.
Try a little bit of that cone.
Hmm, the ice cream tastes nice.
[Prue] Very crunchy praline.
A shame we didn't get the second scoop.
That's a mean ice cream.
Delicious, but not enough.
I wonder if the ice cream
is a bit on the soft side.
I'm trying to keep it neat.
Baker number five,
I'm coming for your bake right now.
[Noel whispers indistinctly]
[Noel laughs]
Down to the wire.
The obvious problem immediately
is that the chocolate
-is just a great ugly lump on top.
-[Paul] Yeah.
[Paul] The wafer's good, good texture.
You do get a little bit of praline.
The ice cream mix itself is good.
It is melting very, very quickly.
It's melting very quickly. Eesh.
Feels weird, like everyone is watching me.
Baker number six, your time is up.
-Thank you.
The wafer looks a little too dark
and too brittle.
And they're over-baked.
The ice cream is nice and smooth.
It's just melting pretty quickly.
[thunder crashing]
[Matt] Paul and Prue will now rank
the ice creams from worst to best.
In sixth spot, we have this one. Syabira.
-Ice cream wasn't set.
-In fifth place, we have this one.
Janusz, it wasn't set, was it?
[Matt] Abdul is fourth and Kevin third.
In second, we have this one.
Maxy, these are pretty good.
You needed to put more ice cream on it
to create a bigger dome.
Which means we have this one. Sandro.
Absolutely delicious.
Nothing wrong with it at all.
-[imperceptible]
-[applause]
I feel great.
I got my first technical win.
[Janusz] They taste great.
They are just more sort of smoothie
than an ice cream. [chuckles]
[Syabira] It's terrible. Er, disappointed.
There's always a rainbow after the rain.
[Syabira sighs] Let's do this.
Four more hours.
Happy Custard Week, everybody.
-Custard Week.
-Who'd have thought it?
[Paul] Coming from northern stock,
anything with custard is good.
You can't just claim custard
for the north, you know?
There's a little village
just outside Bolton called Custard.
-That is where it came from.
-Really?
-No, don't be ridiculous.
-Of course not.
You had me there. We've whittled down
to six really strong bakers now.
It's getting harder and harder.
[Paul] Syabira did well in the signature.
-[Matt] Yeah.
-She was last in the tech.
Whereas Sandro didn't do too well
in the signature with what he did,
but he won the tech.
So, you've got these two
sort of jumping around.
And then you look at everybody else,
they're all again smack in the middle.
Now, you're in this position
where any challenge,
you make one mistake, could go.
Which is harsh, isn't it?
-It's brutal.
-Oh, I can't bear it.
-Wouldn't watch it. Or be involved in it.
-I'd wipe it off my CV.
Good morning, bakers.
Welcome back to the tent
for your showstopper challenge.
Today, Paul and Prue
would like you to bake
an exquisitely decorated
set custard gateau.
[Noel] Your gateau must consist
of multiple baked layers
and be sandwiched and supported
by beautifully flavoured,
perfectly set custard.
You can make any style of gateau you like,
but the set custard elements
must be the star of the show.
I thought Paul Hollywood was the star.
Used to be, now it's set custard.
[Noel] Imagine being usurped
by set custard.
-It's a tough business.
-[Noel laughs]
You have four hours.
-On your marks…
-Get perfectly set…
Bake!
[Sandro] This bake here,
I need this to be perfection.
It's going to be my, like,
"Do I get my Star Baker?"
[Abdul] It's a personal favourite.
So, I'm really excited to make
this and I hope the judges like it.
We've had pouring custard.
We've had frozen custard.
So, for the showstopper,
we're going to have set custard.
There's many different types of custard.
Crème pat, crème diplomat,
crème mousseline.
There has to be baked elements in there.
There are so many
different avenues they could go down.
So, strawberries, I need 400 grams.
I'm gonna just reduce them.
[Prue] There are
lots of ways to set custard.
Most people would use flour,
and a bit of gelatine.
It needs to be silky and soft,
but it must be firm
so that when you get a slice,
it doesn't bulge out.
I am thinking about texture, flavour,
texture, flavour, texture and flavour.
And time. [chuckles softly]
[Paul] Custard gateau has to look amazing.
Lots of flavour, lots of colour.
But custard has to remain the hero.
-Good morning.
-Hello, Syabira.
-[Noel] Hello.
-Hello.
[Prue] Tell us about your custard gateau.
I am making piña colada
custard cake today.
-[Noel laughing]
-There's a theme going on here.
We're getting mojitos,
we're getting piña colada.
-It is a cocktail week.
-Noel and I are big fans of piña colada.
Paul always buys me piña coladas
when we go out.
[Syabira laughs]
[Matt] Syabira's cocktail gateau
will feature
delicate pineapple flowers,
a coconut rum crème légère,
and alternate layers
of pineapple crème pat,
and rum sponge with a tropical ingredient.
I'm adding the coconut milk inside now
to give the coconut taste in the sponge.
I'm excited because I tried this cake
alongside proper piña colada drinks.
Piña colada, cake,
piña colada, cake, piña colada, cake.
[Maxy] This is my joconde sponge.
It's an almond-based sponge.
It's nice and moist.
[Matt] The bakers want baked elements
to be light enough
to avoid compressing
the silky set custard…
I'm making a traditional Polish sponge.
It has both flour and potato starch.
It brings the lightness to the sponge.
…and firm enough
to structure their gateau.
I am going to make a coconut sponge
so it's more robust.
[Matt] While most bakers are using sponges
to support their custards…
Just starting my dough now.
So, I'll start laminating it shortly.
… Abdul has been inspired
to do things differently.
So, I'm making a mille-feuille.
Oh, nice. Tell us about the puff pastry.
So, I tried a rough puff pastry.
I'm actually using your recipe.
-Er, you'll do well with this.
-[laughs]
You're gonna go far, Abdul.
What a move from Abdul. [laughs]
Actually, that recipe is…
I think as good as a puff pastry.
Yes, that's what I noticed as well.
-I did notice there's a slight--
-What's happening here?
Can we just have a moment for this?
[Matt] Abdul's mille-feuille
will be made with layers of compressed
rough puff pastry
that will sandwich chocolate crème
pâtissière and vanilla crème diplomat,
along with strawberries, raspberries,
and caramelised peaches.
But even with Paul's recipe on his side,
he needs to keep his cool.
[Abdul] In this weather,
you incorporate grated frozen butter
to add between the layers
and laminate them.
Ah, my hands are, like, freezing. [laughs]
Frost bites.
[Sandro] This needs to be
in the oven ASAP.
They're gonna go to the oven
for 20 minutes
because they are just small little cakes.
This will go in for about 25 minutes.
[Abdul] So, pastry is
going to be in the fridge.
Chill for about 20, 25 minutes.
[Janusz] Gonna start making my custard.
I'm currently mixing together
cornflour, eggs, and caster sugar.
[Matt] As the bakers move on
to their custards…
[Syabira] Just need to stir it patiently.
My set custard
is really quick and easy to make.
[Matt] …Sandro is chancing
a different method.
I'm doing it through the microwave.
-How?
-[Paul] Explain.
It'll go into microwave for about
30 seconds at a time until it thickens.
So rather than using a pan,
you decided to use a microwave.
[Noel] How do you feel
about the microwave, Paul?
If it works, it works.
[Matt] Sandro's ambitious three tiers
will consist of three different custards.
A vanilla layer, a coffee layer,
and a mango layer.
It'll be decorated with buttercream roses.
All in memory of a very special person.
[Sandro] I wanted to do a tribute
to my friend that I lost.
She was, like, helping me get on here.
I didn't even want to
get on here at the time.
-What? And she encouraged you to--
-She wanted me to join the show, yeah.
She'd have loved a cake
like this for her birthday.
She'd be proud of how you've done.
Yeah, she would be super proud.
[Matt] Sandro's showstopper
isn't the only one
to be inspired by someone special.
[Maxy] Showstopper is a tribute
to my father-in-law who passed away.
He would have been really proud
to hear that I'm in the tent.
I just never got the chance
to let him know.
[Matt] Maxy's gateau will feature
exotic layers
of coconut and almond dacquoise,
joconde sponge,
a lime and passionfruit curd,
and a cascade of tropical fruits.
All set in place with a more
traditional filling.
I am making a crème pat.
Classic vanilla. I wanna keep it simple.
This is supposed to be about the custard.
Yeah. Mmm-hmm.
-It's gonna be the hero, the custard?
-Yeah.
Some bay leaves, some thyme
to infuse with my honey custard.
[Matt] The judges are looking for custards
with perfectly infused flavours.
[Syabira] I'm putting in
pineapple and lime.
I hope this will taste
exactly like a piña colada.
This is my chocolate raspberry custard.
[Matt] Janusz is taking his flavour
inspiration from a favourite holiday.
So, I'm making
Neapolitan set custard gateau.
It's gonna consist
of three different custards.
[Matt] Janusz's trio of custards
will comprise of a dark chocolate
and raspberry custard,
a strawberry and ruby chocolate custard,
and a white chocolate and vanilla custard.
Keeping to his Italian theme,
he is soaking his sponges in limoncello
and finishing off his cake by decorating
with a white chocolate drip.
You practised?
I did practise.
And I baked it in high heels as well.
You baked it in high heels?
Yes, to make sure
that I can walk in those shoes
that I had for Halloween Week.
[all laughing]
So that was me, 6:00 a.m.
in my kitchen, in my high heels.
[Prue] In your high heels.
[in laid-back voice] I feel like there
are two rules in this tent, you know.
It's really important that the bakers
get to express themselves, you know.
Erm, so, er, with that in mind.
Er, bakers!
Er, take as much time as you like
and bake whatever you want.
Paul won't like that.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
-[Maxy] Taking them out of the oven.
-[Syabira] The other cake is ready.
[Maxy] I'm really happy with them.
Pop these in the freezer
so they cool quickly.
So, one… and two.
The puff pastry will try to rise,
but the trays above will compress it.
[Syabira] I need the custard
to be thickened.
I'm using gelatine fully.
[Matt] The consistency of the custard
is key to a successful gateau.
[Sandro] Gonna go into the microwave
for about 30 seconds at a time
until it thickens.
[Matt] And making the perfect silky
but firm custard involves careful timing.
It's a bit grainy,
like, usually it's very smooth.
Maybe it's the cornflour
that I didn't mix in properly.
I'm going to make it again.
Just to be safe.
[Matt] Thicken it too much
and the custard will be gloopy to eat.
[Sandro] See how set this custard is?
[Janusz] That's just right.
Ooh.
[exhaling sharply]
-[Matt] But undercook it…
-[Maxy] A bit worried.
[Matt] …and it could be a sloppy mess.
[Maxy] It's not thickening up.
At home, it would've been done by now.
Pan's not very hot.
You got the wrong one on?
No, no, I haven't. This is the right one.
-It's not very hot.
-[exhales]
At all. That's why.
[Kevin] It should be quite soft
when you slice into it.
That is a big bowl of custard.
I feel like I could jump into that.
I'll use pretty much all of it.
-[Noel] Really?
-[Kevin] Aye. It's a set custard gateau,
-there needs to be… Yeah.
-You need a lot of custard.
Is there such a thing as too much custard?
-[chuckles] No.
-[Noel] No.
[Matt] Kevin's immense three litres
of custard will be decked
with nectarines and raspberries
upon a dacquoise base.
The gateau will be topped
with raspberry jelly
and finished with a cascading swirl
of Swiss meringue buttercream,
Prosecco infused macarons, and bay leaves.
The thyme in there
is going to be interesting
-to see how that works.
-And the bay.
-Bay as well.
-The bay.
-Have you practised this at home?
-Yeah, uh-huh.
And when it comes
to the setting times for each layer,
-have they managed to work okay?
-[Kevin] Yeah, they worked okay.
-[Prue] Oh.
-I'm setting the custard with gelatine.
-So it's like that. It's stacked.
-Yeah.
I think it sounds absolutely wonderful
and I hope you pull it off.
-So do I. [laughs]
-[Paul] Thank you.
Bakers, you have one hour left.
I wish I had three arms, honestly.
Or maybe eight like an octopus.
I'm behind because I had to make
one of my custards again.
I'll try to catch up as much as I can.
[Matt] While some bakers are waiting
for their custards to set…
-[Maxy] Going in the fridge.
-[Matt] …others are ploughing ahead
and assembling their gateau
with unset custard.
The hot custard needs to be set together
with the cake so that it gel together.
[Janusz] I'm just putting the dark
chocolate and raspberry custard in.
[Kevin] And then a thick layer of custard.
[Matt] Working with unset custard
makes it easier to create
the generous layers
the judges are looking for.
The custard layer is about this thick.
Similar.
[Janusz] I want exactly the same
layers of custard to cake.
[Matt] But deeper layers of custard…
-[Syabira] Add another layer.
-[Matt] …require a longer setting time…
-[Kevin] There's a lot of custard.
-[Matt] …to ensure a sturdy showstopper.
[Janusz] It goes to the freezer.
Fridge. I need to let it set
as quick as I can.
-Hopefully it will set on time.
-[sighs]
[Abdul] You can see
it's not fully brown here,
but it's already brown on the edges,
so maybe I'll just take it out now.
I hope this cools
as instantly as possible.
Syabira, we need to let the bakers know
that they've got half an hour left.
-[Syabira] Mmm-hmm.
-Can you tell them all, but in Malay?
Bakers, you have…
[speaks Malay]
-[Noel] You all speak Malay, right?
-[Syabira chuckles]
[laughs]
-It's international language.
-[Noel] Exactly.
Definitely not enough time, but we'll try.
Press speedy mode on.
It's time to assemble now.
So now I'm getting the layers
of the coconut and mango done.
I'm now spreading
the hero of the show, my custard.
[Abdul] It is ready now.
So to add some support,
I added raspberries.
-[Syabira] Set.
-[Kevin] Definitely not set yet.
[Matt] How do you think
this bake is going? You're on schedule?
[Abdul] A bit behind 'cause
I had to make my custard again.
It was grainy and I was like,
"Paul Hollywood will notice that."
-I didn't want--
-He'll put you in custardy.
Yes, he will put me in custardy.
[Maxy] My passion fruit and lime curd.
-That joke was a trifle corny.
-[Abdul chuckles]
[Sandro] Orangey Madeira-type
sponge with vanilla custard.
[Syabira] I am so scared to open it.
[Janusz] But I've touched it
and it's pretty soft.
Still just waiting
for the custard to set.
I'm hoping it will set quite quickly.
-[Syabira] Super jiggly.
-[Abdul] Jiggle-jiggle.
[Janusz laughs]
[Sandro] Now I'm assembling
the joconde sponge
with the coffee custard.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes remaining.
-Cakes.
-[high-pitched] You can do it.
[Abdul] So this is the peach layer.
[Maxy] Pipe with buttercream.
[Sandro] Let's do this like Rufus.
[Syabira] I'm gonna coat them.
White coconut rum, crème légère.
-Crème légère is a whipped custard cream.
-That looks nice. Can I drink that?
-[Syabira] Yep, you can.
-Maybe I'll pour it over my feet.
-That's a custard treatment.
-[laughing] Custard treatment.
It's actually good because all the sugar,
all the butter, is actually moisturising.
I haven't had a custard treatment
for a while, you?
No, never.
Just set. As long as it's set inside.
[sighs, chuckles]
-Would you like me to?
-I'll just turn it.
You're going to try
and pipe in there, right?
[Kevin] Erm, I'm cake-boarding
and doweling every layer.
-Yeah, come on! Strong.
-[Matt] All right.
[Sandro] We ain't got time.
-Pipe really hard.
-I'm doing it.
-Oh, like that. All right.
-There you go. Yeah.
[sighs] It's quite wobbly.
Let's go! Go, go, go!
-Done. Look at that.
-I made a cake!
[Sandro laughs]
[Kevin] That's not stable.
Right. If you get Star Baker,
-I want a cut. Yeah.
-I'm sharing it with you.
-Giving you five percent.
-Yes, please.
All right.
[Kevin] Oh, no.
Not cool, not cool.
The dowels aren't keeping it
stable enough.
I'm going to present it on two stands.
-Bakers, you have five minutes left.
-[Sandro groans]
[Sandro] Getting stressed now.
[Abdul] This is the vanilla custard.
[Janusz] If I'm making a cake,
there will be drip on it.
[Syabira] Hopefully,
the flavour is piña colada.
[Sandro] Really pretty purple roses
and rosettes.
[Syabira] The dried pineapple,
it's gonna be like a flower.
[Janusz] Neapolitan ice cream.
[Abdul] Trying to decorate
as much as I can.
[Syabira] I'm very pleased with it.
[Kevin] I need more time.
[Syabira] Do you need any help?
[Kevin] Trying to
pipe that all over. Just…
[Sandro] I can't stop thinking
of my friend though now.
-You pipe. We pile.
-[Kevin sighs]
-[Janusz] It's three of us. Come on.
-I'm getting a bit overwhelmed.
-It's a very jiggly cake, babes.
-I know.
-Gonna help Kevin.
-[Abdul] Mmm. Yum, yum, yum!
We've got ten seconds.
What do you wanna do?
Some nectarines.
Bakers, your time is up.
[sighs] That'll do, that'll do.
Yeah, that's it.
Please step away from your bakes.
Well done, everybody.
[Kevin sighs]
-[Janusz] Sandro, how did you manage this?
-[Sandro] Er…
Tell me what kind of
witchcraft you used inside.
[Sandro laughs] Witchcraft.
Because that is crazy next-level.
[sighs]
[Matt] It's judgement time for the bakers'
showstopping set custard gateau.
Abdul, would you like
to bring up your showstopper, please?
It looks absolutely lovely, Abdul.
It looks very professional, quite stylish.
[Paul] Let's have a look, shall we?
We have raspberry and chocolate crème pat,
vanilla crème diplomat
with caramelised peaches.
-[Paul] Big enough for you, Prue?
-[chuckles]
[Prue] Now what are you trying
to tell people?
[all laughing]
-Right.
-Paul, you greedy man!
[Paul and Prue chuckle]
The custard in both layers
is definitely the hero.
I think the texture
of the custard's perfect.
-The pastry needed longer in the oven.
-Okay.
Probably needed another five minutes
to get a bit of colour as well,
more than anything else.
Overall, I like the textures
and the flavours.
I think you've got the idea of
a mille-feuille spot on.
-Thank you.
-Really good job.
-[whispers] Well done, Abdul.
-Thank you.
[Noel whispers] You're welcome.
[Abdul whispers] Thank you. [chuckles]
[Paul] It looks impressive.
I like the variety of colours
in the piping. It looks lovely.
-Obviously, the drip.
-And the drip.
-Drip is perfect.
-[all chuckling]
[Janusz] There's a chocolate
and raspberry custard.
There is a ruby chocolate
and strawberry custard
and white chocolate and vanilla custard.
The proportion of custard
to sponge is good.
Sponges are nice.
All the custards are too gloopy
and too dense, too thick on the mouth.
[Prue] It's not fresh enough.
I would've thought all those flavours
would be very fresh.
The custard's more like wallpaper paste.
[Prue chuckles]
-Don't mince words then.
-It is.
Thank you.
[Janusz sighs]
[softly] You okay?
I don't know if it's formal or informal.
I don't know whether it's messy
or very attractive or artistic.
I'm not quite sure how to look at it.
Yeah, I'd say it's slightly messy
and really attractive. [chuckles]
[Matt] It's eclectic.
[all] Wow!
-Look at that.
I think your flavours are great.
Your sponges are good, however…
I'm not sure it celebrates
custard and makes it the hero.
[Prue] This is a beautiful cake.
The sponge is perfect,
the icing is lovely.
The problem is, this was supposed
to be about set custard.
There's very little custard
and none of it is set.
-Thank you, Maxy.
-Thank you.
-[whispers] Well done, Maxy.
-[Maxy] Thank you.
It is a piña colada custard cake.
Well, I think it looks amazing.
It is so unusual.
You actually coated it with custard.
It's much easier to just
slap buttercream all over it.
It's just fantastic.
[Matt] Wobble-icious.
-[Prue] Oh, my goodness.
-[Paul] Wow.
-The amount of custard in there.
-It's great, isn't it?
That's what it's meant to be and it's set.
That custard gateau is impressive.
I've never had one with so much
custard in it and be that stable.
The lime that comes through,
the pineapple and then your coconut,
I think the whole thing together
is just spectacular.
[Prue] The other thing that's
impressive about so much custard
is that it's not too gluey
and it's not rubbery.
I mean, you've just hit it right.
-[Paul] Look at the wobble on that.
-[Prue] I know, like a jelly.
Well done, Syabira.
-[Matt] Well done.
-[Noel] Well done.
[Noel] Smashed it.
[Abdul whispers] Syabira.
[Paul] I think it looks great, very neat.
[Prue] The piping is absolutely exquisite.
It's both bold and modern
and yet very creative.
So the bottom tier sponge is coconut
and you've got the mango custard.
[Prue] Well done.
The second tier in the middle
is a joconde sponge with a coffee custard,
and the top tier is
a orange sponge… [laughs]
…with a vanilla custard.
I think the bottom one's a triumph.
It's clever.
The coconut, mango, it's nice.
[Prue] Mmm. I love it.
That is a wonderfully light sponge.
The coffee sponge is very good.
-Coffee custard's a bit glutinous, dry.
-Okay.
I think every one of those cakes
is highly saleable.
Absolutely delicious.
It would be gobbled up by anybody.
-Well done.
-[Sandro] Thank you.
-Shall I bring this back?
-Thanks, mate.
-[whispers] Well done.
Kevin, would you like to bring up your
set custard gateau showstopper?
-[Matt] Do you want a hand?
-Yeah, please. [chuckles]
-Have we had an earthquake?
-[all laughing]
Well, it's literally
-just dropped as it's opened right up.
-[Kevin] Yeah.
[Paul] All right,
let's have a look at the…
See if we can get a slice.
Erm, so what we have here
is a dacquoise sponge
topped with honey, thyme, and bay.
Set custard topped with raspberry jelly.
Do you know, that custard is amazing.
It's so unusual.
The more you have it in your mouth,
the nicer it is,
and it goes beautifully
with the raspberries.
-[Paul] The thyme and the bay is amazing.
-[Prue] Hmm.
-It works really well together.
-[Prue] Mmm-hmm.
It is delicious.
It's a shame that it looks a mess.
-Yeah. Thank you.
-Thank you.
Well done.
They were ever so nice about the flavours.
They were really, really nice about it.
You know, if there's a bit of hope there,
I'll take it. [laughing]
[Sandro] Feel like I made my friend proud.
I hope I'm in the chance of Star Baker.
'Cause you just never really know.
I think Syabira done a really good job.
[Syabira] It's just unbelievable.
I'm just like, "Did I really make that?"
I feel like I'm just standing there
and I'm accepting it.
But at the same time, I feel like
I'm nearly melting down to the floor
'cause it's just too much to handle.
[Janusz] That didn't went
as well as I planned.
I've made a gloopy custard.
Definitely that puts me in the bottom.
So, it's up to judges.
-[Matt] Well…
-That was a lot of custard.
Yes.
-Or not in some cases.
-[Prue] No.
[Paul] Janusz was disappointing.
[Prue] It wasn't only that
his custards didn't taste great,
they were gluey and spreadable.
-You said wallpaper paste?
-Yes.
How do you even know?
Why have you been eating wallpaper paste?
-[laughter]
-Shall we talk about Kevin?
The flavour were essentially
the best ones in the tent.
-They were amazing.
-[Noel] What, thyme and bay?
But unfortunately the stability
of the whole gateau
was not strong enough, it just collapsed.
If they were set, they were often gloopy,
and if they weren't set, they tasted nice.
You've to get it just right.
And I'll tell you who did,
and that was Syabira.
She really triumphed, didn't she?
[Prue] She had thick custard.
Her flavours were terrific.
-[Matt] It looked great.
-The design was just so modern.
What about Sandro?
He did a lot of work, didn't he?
[Prue] He's always ambitious.
I think two of those cakes
were pretty well perfect.
-The bottom layer, the mango, stunning.
-Mmm-hmm.
Who do you think is in trouble?
I think, Kevin.
-And Janusz is also in line to go now.
-Can't believe that about Janusz.
It tasted awful.
Well done, bakers. That was a tough week.
There were some very impressive bakes.
But there can only be one Star Baker.
And the Star Baker this week is…
Syabira.
[applause]
Oh! Thank you, guys. Thank you.
Okay, that leaves me with the horrible job
of announcing the person
who will be leaving us this week.
And you're such a small little gang now,
it's just going to be horrible.
The person who's leaving us this week is…
Kevin.
Sorry.
-[Paul] Well done, Kevin.
-Thank you. [laughs]
I'm nothing but proud, really. [laughs]
The impostor syndrome is real.
And coming into this competition
I didn't feel like I deserved a place,
but… [laughs]
[imperceptible]
I feel like I can count myself
as one of this talented bunch.
Like… Oh, my.
That custard is just extraordinary.
I'm very sad to see Kevin go,
but that custard will remain with me
for the rest of my life.
I'm going to go home and do it.
I think he's invented something wonderful.
Syabira got Star Baker again
because that was a proper custard gateau.
She just smashed it
on every single department.
-Aren't you a clever girl? Twice?
-Thank you.
I wouldn't have imagined
I would get a Star Baker.
Second in a row. That's wild.
That's one crazy journey
that I had this week.
Honestly, insane.
[Sandro] A little bit sad
I didn't get Star Baker
because I thought that was pretty close.
I'm feeling good to be back
for another week.
We're through to quarter-finals, innit?
-[woman] Yeah.
-I'm through to quarter-finals. [laughs]
Whoo!
[closing theme music playing]